Hello, Dr. Kevin Cutters here and we're gonna talk about some of the male cancers in this section
I understand that when we're diagnosed with cancer, it's a very serious thing even if it's a prostate cancer
That you're put out a watching weight kind of thing. It's always in the back of your head
You're the provider what's gonna happen without you and you're always thinking about it
and it can be confusing sometimes and you're faced with a lot of different decisions
and sometimes if you're diagnosed in later stages, you're faced with decisions to make very quickly
That's not just you that you're thinking about. You're thinking about your spouse. You're thinking about your family
What should you do? I want to let you know that obviously you're watching this video. You're thinking about alternative care
It doesn't have to be a decision of one or the other. That's a common mistake that people make
Can I do alternative care? Well, I don't know why doctors as I should do this
Well, if you're gonna do chemotherapy radiation
Androgen deprimation therapy or surgery, you can still do alternative care together
It's gonna give you a better success right in the end think about it. You're changing the blue
By changing your diet and adding specific nutrition. You're gonna better your
your results by
Improving your immune system and creating a healthier environment for the rest of your cells
But when you decide to okay, maybe I should do some alternative care. Well, then what should I do?
Everybody comes out of the woodwork. Give a you suggestions and it gets very confusing
I don't want to make radical changes to my diet if I don't need to I don't want to take 50 different supplements
Well, when we test we get very specific even when my book we talk about probably a hundred different
Cancer killing nutritional supplements that a person could choose from we don't watch take it even nearly that many
We really want you down to about four or five specific things that are gonna be best for your cancer
And then taking you to off foods that are mainly just the fuel sources of the cancer so that it's not taking away all your joy in life
We test for different frequencies for the right
What's gonna be the best overall to build up your body because ultimately we want success you want success
And that's what we're looking for to understand if you don't choose us for care
That's okay utilize our free information on the site download my books for free and know that will be praying for you no matter what